[Music]
the boom in the Chinese economy is one
of the biggest success stories of our
age but is the East Asian country gets
opened up more it's like more people
want a slice of the pie and that's led
to enterprising people coming up with
their own spin on big-name Western
products we think that there are quite a
few of them we want to try ourselves we
think they might just be better than the
originals keep watching because at the
end of the video you'll find out about a
toothpaste with the difference if this
is your first time visiting the things
then please give this video a big thumbs
up in case a subscribe button today we
are taking a look at 20 Chinese
knockoffs that are actually better than
the original China sportswear we've all
heard of Puma sportswear right but have
you ever thought about what an
inappropriate name that is in case you
don't have a doctorate in zoology a Puma
is basically a rather large kind of cat
and while we love cats we don't think
they're the sort of animals that like to
take part in organized sports or even an
exercise regime but a tuna well that's
different
tunas are fish and fish swim if you're
making swimwear that's a definite one up
over Puma right there and even if you
aren't you might be training as part of
an exercise program that includes
swimming plus tuna is a pretty healthy
food soap China wins that one hey guys
we are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips make a pact and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section cream
between cookies Oreo cookies are one of
America's favorite snack foods but have
you ever stopped to wonder what an Oreo
is we thought it was a small bird which
also gave its name to a major league
baseball team from Baltimore so that was
the Oriole so we had a look and it turns
out that the word was initially used for
the biscuit it has no actual relation to
the food this is unlike cream between
which is a pretty accurate description
of the cookie okay it doesn't say what
the cream is actually between it could
be between bread or some cushions
hypothetically speaking but we say
that's just splitting hairs whoever came
up with the name should have made a
kid detergent tide is when you actually
think of it a pretty odd name to give
something that is meant to wash your
clothes and make them clean we get it
the idea that it's like washing your
clothes in the sea but do you know what
sea pollution is like these days it's
really bad
so yeah sure give your clothes a watch
that will leave them potentially
smelling of plastic detritus and far far
worse or it's the very least incredibly
salty no we prefer the Chinese brand kid
did you know that tid is an
old-fashioned word meaning tender soft
nice no we think that we'd like our
detergent to be those three things
that's why we go with Ted every time
Obama fried chicken while we love a good
KFC we'll admit that maybe Colonel
Sanders isn't the best iconic company
could have let's put it this way if it
wasn't for his fried chicken would you
have heard of him probably not but
everyone's heard of Barack Obama right
unfortunately for the enterprising
person who set up this restaurant in
Beijing the company behind KFC thought
the image of the former president was a
bit too similar to Harland Sanders so
they made them get rid of it mr. Obama's
thoughts on the matter are as yet
unknown he wouldn't be the first
ex-president to get his name on a
chicken shop either there's a Kennedy
chicken and pizza in Barking Essex
England special man can you think of
something that you can describe as super
we're sure you can but there's a problem
and that problem is that everyone's
definition of super varies oh sure you
may think something is super but for
someone else that could be reasonable
for someone else it could be pretty
dashed awful and fair play to that
person for obviously coming from the
1890s but anyway super is a subjective
thing so even for Superman we're sure
someone from the planet Krypton could
argue he's actually nothing to write
home about man that's why we like this
guy he's special man if something is
special we can generally all agree that
it is and we like his haircut to kick
her chocolate bar the old advertising
slogan used to tell us to have a break
have a kit kat all very well and good
who wouldn't like to unwind with these
chocolate coated wafers
but as with so many things there was a
problem the problem was that Kit Kats
had a very similar name to kite cat that
was a type of cat food we're sure that
people who wanted the Kit Kat might have
asked someone to get them a kite cat by
mistake which would have caused big
problems unless that person had a cat
and even then the cat might not have
liked
brand which is why we think it is a huge
relief to ask for a kicker bar like you
can in China polystation Sony
PlayStation's have been a phenomenal
success selling millions of units over
four generations but don't you think
that as a brand name PlayStation sounds
a bit Wells pedestrian we know what
railway stations are and they can be
pretty awful places you try paying over
the odds in a vending machine for a pack
of potato chips while it turns out your
train is delayed because of cows on the
line does it make you want to play does
it that's why we like the idea of a poly
station it's still a station but it's a
station where there's a lot of stuff
going on that means that we can feel as
suitably excited as we think we should
do mighty car a lot of people who grew
up anywhere near the 1980s will have
loved the a-team let's face it it was
brilliant two things stand out as being
particularly fantastic one of them was
the gangs of bands it was black but it
has this cool looking red stripe on it
we wanted a family that the second thing
was the character of ba Baracus as
portrayed by mr. t so this toy is the
a-team van but it's got ba Baracus as
head it's like they fuse the two best
things together and made it even more
amazing we'd like to know when else have
two brilliant things come together to
make something even better
III Bo we aren't even sure where to
start with this one is that good the
premise is there are two gigantic
pop-culture movies from the late 70s and
early 80s one is Star Wars and the other
is etz extra-terrestrial they both
feature iconic characters but have you
ever looked at ET and funny be better if
you were a robot or looked at c-3po from
Star Wars and thought he'd be more
interesting if you look like ET we're
sure you have we do little bit around
our place so hats off to the genius who
came up with this it's et as a droid its
c-3po with et's face it's both it's
neither it's left us quite literally
speechless Thomas the transformer engine
millions of children across the world
have fallen in love with the tales of
Thomas the Tank Engine but just as many
have fallen in love with the transformer
so the idea of the Super Robot
transformer Thomas is in our humble
opinion raw undiluted pure genius
wouldn't Thomas and Friends be even
better if he was able to manipulate
himself to become a giant robot and
isn't that what the Reverend W Audrey
was aiming at in his books well he
probably wasn't but that's only because
the Transformers weren't a saying in
nineteen
forty's England if they had he totally
would have been we're waiting for the
Transformers Thomas crossover movie word
on the hollywood street is that it's
going to starve in diesel new-style
ninja tortoise party yawning Cowabunga
dudes we were kids growing up we loved
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles it was
amazing
there was one built-in problem with it
what was going to happen once our
sewer-dwelling heroes turned 20 if
nothing else it's going to mess with the
scansion of the lyrics and that is
something that quite literally nobody
wants the other thing is we can't quite
remember what the difference between a
turtle and the tortoises either come to
think of it wouldn't it tortoise be a
more common pet to find in new york city
so a new settlement of tortoise that's
pretty cool and it's kind of timeless to
the iPhone boot like it or lo that the
Apple iPhone has revolutionized cell
phone since it was first introduced back
in the late 2000s it might seem hard to
remember but the idea of a phone that
was purely operated by touchscreen was
really fresh most Mobile's in those days
either had a hard keyboard or a stylus
attached but this was something else so
what one smart Chinese entrepreneur did
was try to get the excitement of the
iPhone and turn it into a piece of
footwear while some people would prefer
an Android phone more people have a need
for something to put on their feet we
reckon these are long lasting items
there's no need to keep rebooting these
iPhones dolce and banana we would like
to at least think that we are dedicated
followers of fashion here it's a thing
we try our best to know our brands and
know just what exactly is on trend this
season but we are also fans of good
healthy food too and when that's
combined with a good pun we give that a
thumbs up talking of which you should
totally give this video a thumbs up
anyway this particular Chinese brand hit
all three targets it's clearly a tribute
to top Italian fashion house Dolce and
Gabbana but it also pays homage to one
of our favorite fruits the banana and
did you know that Dolce is Italian for
sweets and with sleep a banana brilliant
stuff demon donkey one of the more
bizarre pop culture phenomena of the
21st century is the appearance of the so
called brony they are male fans of the
My Little Pony Friendship is Magic TV
show although the program's target
audience is young girls grown-up men
have got into the show in a big way
they've been drawn into the program
scenes of
loyalty friendship and unity but what if
the original My Little Pony had appealed
to little boys in the 1980s it could
have done so pretty easily had it
created demon donkey this Chinese
creation looks like a nice pony but it's
a demon
it'll probably cause a pretty cool chaos
and that's something that both boys and
girls of all ages can enjoy Harry Potter
and the leopard walk up to dragons it's
highly unlikely that there's anyone
under the age of 30 in the Western world
who has never read a Harry Potter book
they've managed to make both reading and
wearing glasses cool and they're great
stories whose plots and characters live
on in the hearts of readers but you know
what other book does that The Hobbit
ever wonder what would happen if you
took JRR Tolkien's classic work and
populated it with characters from the
Potter verse we bet you have but someone
from China already did it the end result
is Harry Potter and the Leopards walk up
to dragon a book which literally
replaces all the characters in The
Hobbit with Potter ones except for
Gandalf does this mean he's the best
wizard Iike Homer when we think of
classic yellow animated characters there
are two ones that come to mind the first
is Pikachu he's the little yellow guy
from Pokemon whether you are talking
about Nintendo's iconic video game or
the spin-off cartoon he is a franchise
mascot you might also think about Homer
Simpson at the accident-prone
beer-guzzling patriarch of the Simpsons
is an icon of our age considering the
number of jobs he's had such as
astronaut country and western singer
manager and farmer this makes sense
we're sure the creators of The Simpsons
could find a link between homer and the
pokemons go craze that's what this
person did and they put it on a sock and
that's why we love them for it who you
gonna call spook chasers people who grew
up in the 1980s and 1990s are likely to
have very fond memories of the Real
Ghostbusters cartoon for a certain
generation of people this is the
Ghostbusters they remember rather than
the movie kind but we remember having
one problem with the whole idea of
Ghostbusters and that was that we were
never entirely sure how busted the
ghosts were and even if we had to call
on their services we're not sure whether
we'd want to actually have ghosts busted
so to speak that's why we prefer the
idea of someone in China hat of spook
chasers they aren't going to hurt the
ghosts they're just going to chase them
away that's the sort of spirit that we
like to
son bucks coffee sometimes it seems like
Starbucks has taken over the world
and while we are partial to a cup of
Starbucks we can't help but feel a
little jealous of Chinese people at
least the Chinese people who get to grab
a delicious Sun bucks coffee why do we
prefer it well two reasons firstly you'd
think it would be a heck of a lot easier
to grow coffee where there was Sun
rather than stars from trying to
remember our high school biology lessons
that's what's called photosynthesis
secondly have you seen the logo we're
never sure what a mermaid has got to do
with coffee but an awesome Chinese style
dragon demon thing here she could
totally roast some beans by breathing
fire on them like just do it
even we'll have to admit that naming
your sports brand after the Greek
goddess of victory is way cool it's what
Nike did it's like you want your win not
to just be the result of hard work and
smart preparation no you'll also believe
that it's to do with the divine powers
of your sports uniform but what if we
don't want to base our triumphs on a
belief system that with all due respect
died out more than 2,000 years ago what
if we wanted to be about how much we
enjoy what we're doing so that's why we
are going to say that the Chinese brand
light gets our vote crusts toothpaste
what's the thing that you don't want to
have on your teeth it's probably some
sort of plaque or to use a non medical
term crust so what could be more
appealing than a mention of crusts to
get you to brush your teeth think about
it if you see crest on your toothpaste
and you'll just think of heraldry and is
there any relationship between heraldry
and oral hygiene nope but you see crest
and you think that you'd better not have
Krusty cheese it's subliminal reverse
psychology in advertising so that's way
better but that kind of thinking when is
someone used reverse psychology on you
to get you to do something tell us in
the comments that's all for our 20
Chinese knockoffs that are actually
better than the original if you liked it
why not check out five cartoon reboots
that are way better than the original
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]